Aw yeah! Let's learn English with
the new Lion King movie!
So, if you're anything like me,
the original Lion King was probably
quite a highlight of your youth.
And that's why I thought that with this
new version, it would make a perfect lesson
for you guys.
We have some interviews with
the entire cast,
including Beyonce, and some clips
from the new movie.
And every week we help learners to understand
fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Parmida, who says that
with our lessons,
she has taken her English to the next level.
So if you want to be able to
improve your English too,
we would love to help you to do it.
You just have to that Subscribe button,
and the bell down
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Hey! So, I know you're watching this
because you're passionate about English fluency.
And, so, I wanted to let you know
that from now until July 20th,
it's FLUENCY WEEK, in order to celebrate
hitting 700,000 subscribers on
Learn English with TV Series (almost 750k now),
and to thank you for
all of your support for all of our lessons,
we wanted to give you
a really huge opportunity over the next year
to take your English fluency to the next level
with a 33% Discount on our premium course,
Fluent with Friends!
Just like Clover, who says that she's had a
much more real-life learning experience
than in school.
Wouldn't you just love if this time next year,
you could confidently understand
all of your favorite movies and series,
without subtitles in English?
Well, to learn more about the course
and sign up,
simply click up here,
or down in the description below
and remember to get your 33% OFF,
just use the coupon code 700k  at checkout.
And, hurry, because this offer
is only available for a few more days!
I look forward to seeing you
inside the Fluency Circle,
and let's continue with the lesson.
Alright! I hope you enjoyed that lesson a lot,
and that it will be really beneficial for you
in going to see the new Lion King movie.
And, remember - don't miss out on
this big opportunity for your English fluency
at a small price:
Check out Fluent with Friends!
And remember to use your coupon code
700k at checkout to get 33% OFF.
Be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
a single one of our new lessons!
Check out this playlist of videos
teaching you English with movies,
and this other lesson I know that you're going to love.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww yeah!